et une demi-heure spéciale consacrée au
fond Marianne la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale a rendu son rapport
accablant pour Marlène Schiappa on va en
parler avec vous onion Roger merci
d'être avec nous journaliste à Mediapart
et Quentin vous avez réalisé vous un
documentaire fond Marianne le
détournement d'un symbole qui serait
diffusé ce soir à 17h30 sur notre
antenne on va en voir des extraits
évidemment tout au long de cette
demi-heure d'abord enchaîne un mot avec
vous qu'est-ce qui vous alerté dans ce
fond Marianne pourquoi vous avez
travaillé sur ce sujet
et un fiasco extrêmement grave et
important je pense qu'il faut il faut
quand même rappeler le contexte de ce
fond Marianne c'est d'abord de l'argent
public un peu plus de 2 millions d'euros
qui a été distribué à des associations
pour une politique publique extrêmement
importante et sensible à savoir la
promotion des valeurs républicaines
contre les discours portant à la
radicalisation etc et autour d'un
symbole celui de l'assassinat du
professeur Samuel Paty qui a ému
de la France donc il est évident que il
était nécessaire de savoir dans quelles
conditions ont été distribuées ces fonds
là et quel et quels ont été les
conséquences des opérations qui étaient
censées être censée réaliser par les
associations attributaires du fond
Marianne et ce dont on se rend compte
aujourd'hui
d'abord à travers les révélations de la
presse et puis aujourd'hui confirmé par
par les les résultats de la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale mais aussi de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration du ministère de
l'Intérieur et bien c'est que à la fois
le processus de sélection des
associations n'était pas équitables en
gros qui s'agissait d'un appel à projet
truqué et en plus de cela que les deux
principaux bénéficiaires de ce fond
Marianne qui ont récolté plus de 180 780
mille euros de promesses de subvention
et bien n'ont pas réalisé les missions
pour lesquelles ils étaient censés
bénéficier de cet argent donc le
scandale est absolument énorme en
l'occurrence et on va revenir là-dessus
surtout ce je vous avais parlé en John
puisque du coup le Sénat a enquêté
Quentin commission d'enquête sénatoriale
qui a rendu ses travaux en fin de
semaine dernière et vous vous avez suivi
cette commission d'enquête vous en avez
fait un documentaire qu'on va voir cet
après-midi sur notre antenne qu'est-ce
qu'on voit dans ce documentaire Quentin
le point de départ c'est bien une
enquête journalistique de nos confrères
de Marianne et de France Télévisions
mais sauf qu'à un moment le politique
s'en empare et c'est lorsque ces
révélations apparaissent que
effectivement des sénateurs en
l'occurrence socialiste vont d'abord
demander des documents pour voilà
contrôler sur pièces tout d'abord ce qui
se joue autour de ce fond Marianne et
ensuite ils vont décider au vu de ce
qu'ils ont comme document qui leur sont
transmis d'ouvrir une commission
d'enquête donc l'idée du documentaire
c'est de retracer toutes les auditions
parce qu'effectivement il y avait tout
ce que la presse avait dit et il y a eu
tout ce qu'on a appris ensuite par ces
auditions qui ont une particularité
c'est que les personnes qui sont
convoquées ne peuvent pas refuser d'être
reçu au Sénat et doivent prêter serment
donc dire toute la vérité ce qui jette
une lumière particulièrement crue sur
les témoignages des personnes qui sont
convoquées et en plus qu'il l'était
parfois sur deux trois heures pour
s'expliquer en profondeur et les
sénateurs le disent de même à chaque
audition de personnalité qui a été
convoquée il y a eu deux trois nouvelles
informations et révélations par rapport
à ce qu'on savait même de ce qu'avait
dit la presse de la faire
avant de parler de la méthode
effectivement Quentin le dit et Claude
Raynal le dit d'ailleurs dans votre
documentaire Quentin il y a pas une
audition où on n'a pas appris un deux
trois fait il y a une véritable utilité
de cette commission d'enquête d'ailleurs
la leçon de ce fond Marianne c'est que
c'est que il reste des contre-pouvoirs
efficaces à la fois le travail de la
presse complété par par ses auditions et
aussi la capacité des membres de la
commission d'enquête sanatoriale aller
chercher des documents et notamment sur
toute la partie de sélection au moment
de l'appel à projet du fond Marianne et
bien c'est le travail de la commission
d'enquête qui a permis vraiment d'aller
au ministère de l'Intérieur récupérer
des documents pour voir par exemple
qu'il n'y avait pas de grille d'analyse
des candidatures au moment de la
sélection des projet mais c'est
exactement le point de départ aussi de
du documentaire effectivement Ariane
puisque la méthode des sénateurs ça va
être de tout d'abord convoquer les
responsables de l'administration puisque
en fait il y a le cabinet de Marlène
Schiappa qui est l'autorité politique
qui s'appelle le ministère à l'époque le
ministère délégué la citoyenneté donc le
mystère de machiava qui d'ailleurs
récupère en fait le fond Marianne toute
l'instance le cipdr qui va gérer le fond
Marianne lorsque Marlène Schiappa arrive
au gouvernement en 2020 et donc ce cipdr
pour comité interministériel de
prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation c'est donc cette
structure administrative pilotée par le
préfet Gravel qui doit définir une
méthode de travail ensuite est chargé
cochargé de choisir les lauréats du fond
Marianne et on va se rendre compte que
il y a une forme d'opacité autour du
travail de ce comité interministériel et
c'est tout l'extrait que on va voir le
premier extrait Oriane ou effectivement
le préfet Gravel donc qui est en charge
ce comité interministral et reçu c'est
donc le tout premier convoqué on regarde
un extrait
l'audition est longue et parfois un peu
tendue les sénateurs cherchent à
comprendre comment étaient sélectionnés
les associations et n'obtiennent pas de
réponse à leurs questions je ne sais
toujours pas quelles ont été les
critères qui ont permis d'effectuer la
sélection et ce qui est aussi important
comment vous avez choisi de
d'attribuer des sommes de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros à
certaines associations et pas d'autres
je vais tâcher d'y répondre monsieur
rapporteur la nature même de cette
opération
ne contribue pas à
la simplicité sur le fait de pouvoir
envisager une grille d'analyse commune
dès l'instant où il y a un appel à
projet il doit y avoir un compte rendu
de la commission d'attribution et de
sélection et puis il doit y avoir des
éléments tangibles qui permettent de
dire pourquoi telle association est
retenue et pour faire quoi
lorsque l'on voit une procédure
extrêmement opaque au final bien on peut
pas être satisfait par rapport à ce qui
est le principe même d'un appel à projet
et Quentin ça fait partie des choses
qu'on retient c'est la véritable opacité
dans l'attribution de chauffage
les sénateurs dans leur rapport et qui
est concordant est-ce que dit au même
moment l'inspection générale de
l'administration qui est donc la
troisième enquête avec celle de la
justice et celle des sénateurs qui est
aussi eu tout son cours pendant
l'affaire et elle IgA donc qui rendra un
rapport parcellaire au début du mois de
juin puis là la semaine dernière en même
temps que le rapport des dessinateurs et
qui relève aussi ce manque de
transparence donc là les sénateurs et
avait en fait déjà le rapport de l'ija
pour pour soulever ce caractère ils ont
plus que de lui faire la démonstration
avec l'audition de de Gravel de du
préfet Gravel au Sénat il y a une
véritable opacité dans l'attribution de
ce fond oui non seulement c'est opaque
mais c'est inéquitable et c'est ça
peut-être le le plus grave je pense que
et les sénateurs et l'igéa se serait
peut-être contenté d'une forme d'opacité
si ça avait été quand même assez
argument derrière ça en l'occurrence ce
dont on a aujourd'hui la certitude c'est
que des associations proches
idéologiquement ou même par lien
d'amitié de certains responsables du
fond Marianne ont été prévenus en amont
pour candidater à fond et donc pour
bénéficier d'argent public quand
d'autres associations qui pour certaines
d'entre elles travaillent de longue date
avec avec l'appareil étatique avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur etc n'était pas
au courant de l'existence de ce fond et
l'ont été en toute fin de de course et
donc n'ont pas pu présenter leurs
projets donc il y a une vraie distorsion
de concurrence de ce point de vue là qui
pose évidemment des questions légales
mais aussi ne serait-ce que éthique et
politique dans le cadre d'une politique
publique encore je le rappelle
extrêmement symbolique et et
sérieuse et la difficulté derrière c'est
que les deux associations qui ont
bénéficié
donc de d'une forme de qui ont été
favorisés dans cet appel à projet par
cette opacité parce qu'elles ont été
prévues prévenu en amont sont
précisément celle pour lesquelles
ensuite il y a eu des dérapages et des
insuffisances au moment de au moment de
de la conduite des opérations on peut
les citer ces deux associations c'est
l'uspm qui est la principale
bénéficiaire du Fonds Marianne et qui
est codirigé par le polémiste Mohammed
cifaoui et la seconde c'est reconstruire
le commun qui est l'association qui va
distiller des messages politiques y
compris pendant les campagnes
présidentielles et législatives
effectivement ce sont ce sont deux
associations dont l'une à lui se ppm
qu'on a été chercher voilà qui est qui a
pu candidater alors même que le fond
Marianne n'avait toujours pas été
annoncé à l'époque
dans quelques instants Christian Gravel
qu'on a entendu il exprime pas de regret
pendant son audition un seul regret sur
le calendrier il dit que lui il voulait
trois mois que le cabinet de la ministre
a parlé de 5 semaines
c'est le seul regret qu'il
voilà va formuler pendant son audition
il va même dire que le bilan global du
fond Marianne est positif et qu'on l'a
pas assez relevé alors il va essayer de
jouer sur le nombre de publications le
nombre de contenus alors ça on le voit
dans le documentaire en fait il dit que
un tweet de l'uspm ça faisait un contenu
et sénateurs disent voilà 355000 euros
508 ça fait cher le tweet en quelque
sorte mais oui voilà dès le départ
effectivement il y a un souci autour de
ces subventions évidemment le temps fort
qu'on attendait de cette commission
d'enquête sénatoriales Quentin c'est
l'audition de Marlène Schiappa voilà
tout à fait alors elle était censée
arriver même à la toute fin des
auditions sauf que mytifaoui va être
voilà excusé pour des raisons de de
santé puis parce qu'il est
perquisitionné par la justice donc c'est
finalement c'est pas la toute dernière
audition mais mais c'est mais c'est
quasiment l'une des dernières et ça va
c'est celle qui va laisser le plus le
sentiment d'inachevé au sénateur qui
était présent dans la salle les
sénateurs qui vont regretter le niveau
de réponse de Marlène Schiappa avec tous
les moments où elle dit je ne sais pas
je ne m'en souviens plus je n'ai pas la
preuve matérielle que comme s'il fallait
qu'elle ait un mail pour être obligé de
parler d'un sujet et elle va souvent
renvoyer vers son administration donc
vers le cipdr ouvert son cabinet vers
des membres de son cabinet qui ne
l'auraient pas sollicité forcément ce
qui ne veut pas empêcher les sénateurs
de faire un reproche à Marlène Schiappa
c'est son manque de portage politique
écouter donc c'est le deuxième extrait
de ce documentaire
au cours de cette audition les sénateurs
en profitent pour dénoncer le faible
suivi de la ministre du fond Marianne il
y a eu une forte annonce puissante
communication et après plus rien voilà
je voulais répondre voilà bien sûr merci
monsieur
matérialité dans les échanges de mails
entre mon cabinet et moi-même et des
notes dans lesquelles nous voulons
relancer le fond Marianne il y a une
note de projet suite à la demande de ma
part et à échange et suite justement à
discussion avec le cabinet
l'administration sur ce sujet l'un de
mes conseillers prépare un futur appel à
projet pour l'année qui suit sur le fond
Marianne donc nous voulons nous
entendons poursuivre cette politique
publique
donc vous conviendrez et vous ne m'avez
pas démenti qu'il n'y a pas de
communication particulière après le
lancement il y a l'annonce du fond
Marianne il y a la sélection le projet
vit sa vie il y a plus de communication
voilà il n'a plus une bénéficie plus du
même portage et surtout du même éco
médiatique la responsabilité d'un
ministre ne s'arrête pas au lancement
d'une opération la responsabilité du
ministre s'arrête aux résultats et
lorsqu'on a effectivement obtenu des
résultats
on peut d'ailleurs revenir devant les
Français et devant la presse pour faire
état de résultats c'est très important
c'est ça la responsabilité ministérielle
et d'une certaine façon
elle dénit un peu cette responsabilité
qu'est-ce qui a révélé l'audition de
Marlène Schiappa Antoine pour vous une
grande incohérence en réalité parce que
le fond Marianne c'est le projet de
Marlène Schiappa elle va énormément
communiquer dessus au moment de son
lancement c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
le calendrier de l'appel à projet va
être resserré contrairement aux demandes
de l'administration on le fait
rapidement parce que elle a besoin de en
termes de publicité de d'aller dans les
médias et d'annoncer le lancement de de
ce fond Marianne on l'a vu aussi au
moment des auditions c'est que elle est
elle est vraiment en laisse courte dans
la gestion de de son administration et
tout ça et deux ans ou deux ans et demi
après elle vient expliquer devant une
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sous
serment qu'elle n'était finalement au
courant au courant absolument au courant
de rien donc c'est vraiment
elle se dégage totalement de sa
responsabilité politique et c'est ce qui
fait dire
aux rapports sénatorial que en fait
c'est la dérive d'un coup de
communication c'est à dire que le seul
intérêt de Marlène Schiappa dans la dans
le fond Marianne c'était finalement son
annonce sa publicité au moment de sa
création et qu'ensuite les conséquences
néfastes aujourd'hui et désastreuses en
termes de gaspillage argent public
notamment et bien les assume pas elle
dit qu'elle se qu'elle s'en occupait pas
et c'est vrai que c'est toujours
extrêmement déstabilisant et vertigineux
de voir un ministre une ministre en
l'occurrence qui est toujours au
gouvernement aujourd'hui rejeter la
faute pendant de longues heures devant
une commission d'encaisse sur son
administration voir sur des membres de
son cabinet et de n'assumer absolument
rien en croisant les doigts sur le fait
qu'il n'existe pas de traces écrites de
ce qu'elle peut alléguer devant devant
les sénateurs il y avait une stratégie
Marlène Chapa Claude rénale dans dans le
documentaire et vous dit elle était dans
une vision dans une volonté d'en dire le
moins possible
enfin c'est ce que dit ça c'est la thèse
c'est l'hypothèse que soulève le
sénateur effectivement dans le
documentaire c'est qu'elle aurait été
conseillé alors soit par un conseiller
politique ou par son avocat personnel
d'en dire le moins possible c'est une
hypothèse mais afin que si jamais les
les poursuites judiciaires venaient à 7
ans elle puisse pas être inquiétée pour
ce qu'elle a dit sincèrement et voilà ce
que dit Claude rénale dans le
documentaire c'est que la seule présence
du parc national financier dans le
dossier fait qu'elle est très prudente
voilà il en dit pas plus mais c'est
sous-entendu et on va revenir sur le
manque de portage politique parce que
effectivement
le sénateur Russon et Claude Raynal en
ont beaucoup parlé mais un mot sur
Mohamed Sifaoui parce que c'est aussi un
personnage clé de cette affaire du fond
Marianne Quentin on le disait il y a une
association qui est particulièrement
pointée du doigt c'est la sienne le
seppm voilà il en était le responsable
éditorial et donc c'est l'association
qui va être la principale bénéficiaire
du fond alors même ils vont demander au
départ une subvention de 1,5 millions
d'euros sur plusieurs années sur trois
ans donc c'est qui veulent monter un
projet vraiment extrêmement ambitieux
puis la somme va être rabotée à 600.000
euros puis
355000 euros mais le résultat de cette
association interroge on le disait tout
à l'heure on parle de 500 tweets une
dizaine de vidéos sur Youtube avec
quelques centaines de vues pour les plus
vues et effectivement au milieu de tout
ça un personnage un peu sulfureux le
polémisme un expert des réseaux
islamisation etc mais son audition va
être marqué au Sénat par de vivre
tension on en a gardé un extrait dans le
documentaire on peut le regarder aussi
la réponse de Claude Raynal dans notre
documentaire plus tard dans son propos
le polémiste accusera certains
politiques de l'acheter une audition
marquée par un niveau de tension encore
jamais atteint au Sénat vous êtes
parfaitement je dirais sur la même
posture ou explication que la ministre
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
concerné par le projet mais vous
finalement vous tenez à distance pour
qu'il y ait je dirais pas de souci
non donc vous donnez vous permettre je
ne vous permettra je vous demande juste
je vous permets pas je suis de juste
préciser je le précise rien du tout vous
allez retirer tout de suite ce que vous
voulez dire aucune posture chez moi vous
entendez il y a aucune posture je ne
suis pas un homme politique il y a
aucune posture déclaration vous tout de
suite je n'ai rien de comparable avec
Madame Schiappa c'est clair celui qui
percénaire est toujours en difficulté au
final bon et peut-être y a-t-il là une
façon de vouloir
se sortir de questions qu'il embarrasse
tout simplement voilà ça en dit long
aussi quand même sur la
qualité du partenaire pour l'État
et je pense que
malheureusement pour lui monsieur
Sifaoui n'a pas donné une bonne image
lors de cette audition Antoine c'était
assez déconcertant quand même cette
audition de mametifaoui on l'a vu tout à
l'heure avec Marlène Schiappa c'était
vraiment l'irresponsabilité là c'est un
conséquence enfin en réalité on voit que
on voit qu'on a effectivement face au
sénateur quelqu'un qui était présenté
y compris dans l'audition de Christian
Gravel comme une caution scientifique du
fond Marianne justifiant certes peu de
production mais une production
extrêmement qualitative et tout ça en
fait on se rend compte que on a
quelqu'un qui n'arrive même pas à se
contrôler en réalité qui est insultant
qui est parfois à côté de la plaque
comprend même pas certaines questions
qui lui sont posées et c'est vrai que
au-delà de au-delà du fond Marianne ça
interroge effectivement sur la fiabilité
des relations des acteurs qui qui
interagissent avec quand même le plus
haut sommet de l'État sur des politiques
publiques
extrêmement extrêmement grave et
importante parce que Mohamed kifaoui il
était consultant pour le CIP d'air donc
le comité interministériel de prévention
de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation et travailler avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur il était aussi
en interaction avec l'Élysée au moment
de la préparation la loi séparatisme etc
et c'est vrai que il y a toujours un
effet de dévoilement dans ce type de
commission d'enquête mais comme ça avait
été le cas aussi au moment de l'affaire
Benalla où on se rend compte que des
gens au plus haut sommet de l'État ou en
tout cas qui conseille le plus haut de
ce sommet de l'État sont en réalité
parfois dans des pratiques ou dans des
raisonnements assez assez douteux donc
je trouve que c'est quand même au-delà
de au-delà de la dimension de l'argent
public qui a été mobilisée autour du
fond Marianne c'est aussi cette affaire
là il y a interroger une vision
politique la fiabilité de certains
acteurs qui se sont retrouvés quand même
au cœur de ce dispositif pour certains
d'entre eux pour une seule et bonne
raison c'est qu'il partager une vision
idéologique de Marlène Schiappa sur une
perception de la laïcité de combat
étriqué etc un mot sur le contrat que
vous venez de mentionner puisque c'est
une des révélations là encore de cette
audition c'est que effectivement Mohamed
cifaoui qu'on vient de voir dans
l'extrait en fait travailler pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur depuis
l'automne 2020 donc au moment même où se
mène la réflexion sur la mort de Samuel
Paty au moment où effectivement et il y
a une grande constatation qui est
Monique des intellectuels sur le projet
de loi séparatisme mais donc on comprend
qu'il est en fait dans les rouages du
ministère de l'Intérieur bien avant que
le fond Marianne ne soit ne soit lancé
ou même évoqué en réunion formelle du
cabinet et d'ailleurs ça Oriane c'est
une des informations que la commission
d'enquête va envoyer au parquet national
financier puisque c'est l'une des
annonces qui ont été faites en fin de
semaine dernière mais il y a des
éléments nouveaux qui ont été découvert
lors des auditions sous serment et que
les les sénateurs n'avaient vu nulle
part ailleurs dans le dossier qui vont
donc transmettre à la justice voilà
Claude Raynal il dit que qu'il a saisi
le parquet national passer d'un
complément d'information lui
transmettant un certain nombre de
documents est-ce qu'on sait précisément
lesquelles quand on sait que ce contrat
notamment
ça fait partie des éléments je crois
qu'il y en a trois ou quatre c'est l'un
des voilà il est resté assez flou
contrat qui a quand même été passé avec
une société
amie de Mohamed
ifaoui dans l'objet social initial était
quand même la vente de chaussures donc
ça ça interroge je ne savais pas qu'on
pouvait passer des des prestations de
service ou devenir consultant pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur je rappelle
quand même le cadre dans lequel tout
cela se passe avec une entreprise de
vente de chaussures le ministère est à
chercher à trouver les les coquilles qui
pouvaient voilà obtenir les subventions
tout comme lui seppm était une
association qui vivait 50 000 euros de
budget 5 membres mais qu'on va mettre en
avant pour en fait envoyer des
subventions à ma petite ah oui Quentin
l'un des principaux reproches des
sénateurs c'est d'avoir toucher un
symbole important celui de la mort de
Samuel Paty voilà effectivement on en
vient à ce que vous disiez c'est une
lutte très importante la lutte contre la
radicalisation en ligne enfin le drame
de la mort du professeur de Samuel Paty
et ben c'était aussi ça c'était qui
avait des gens qui s'était radicalisés
en ligne et non pas par des mosquées ou
des réseaux en prison etc mais bien par
internet donc toute la volonté du fond
Marianne c'était de d'aller créer un
contre discours en se servant du symbole
de la mort de Samuel Paty comme voilà
d'un déclencheur d'une réflexion et donc
le lien avec le l'assassinat timelapiti
il aurait dû mener à une grande prudence
politique et c'est ça l'un des
enseignements du documentaire de ce soir
et c'est aussi l'une des leçons des
sénateurs on peut regarder le dernier
extrait
fiasco Gashi les sénateurs disent
dresser un constat sans appel dans un
combat pourtant essentiel et légitime la
lutte contre la radicalisation
nous avons le sentiment que le fond
Marianne a été conçu comme une grande
opération de communication par la
ministre
alors que la discrétion et l'efficacité
aurait certainement dû constituer les
lignes directrices majeures le label du
fond Marianne devient un véritable
fardeau
je dirais même un boulet attaché à
l'élégorie de la République
[Musique]
le plus grave dans l'affaire selon les
sénateurs c'est la promesse rompue
formuler après la mort de Samuel Paty
par son manque d'éthique et de
transparence le gouvernement a entaché
la mémoire du professeur d'histoire-géo
l'attention réduit être maximale sur ce
dossier elle est maximale parce que
c'est sur la base
d'un assassinat horrible que c'est dans
la mémoire de beaucoup de Français et
que donc par rapport à cela on a une
exigence de faire au mieux bien sûr le
fond Marianne n'aurait pas tout résolu
bien entendu mais au moins le mener dans
la continuité moi je comprends
parfaitement que la famille du
professeur que vous avez cité ne
souhaite plus que ce nom soit associé à
cette affaire du fond de Marianne
les mots sont forts on l'entend quand
Jean-François ils sont parlent de
boulets attachés à l'allégorie de la
République c'est aussi ça les
conséquences de cette affaire du fond
Marianne ça a abîmé les valeurs de la
République si on fait le bilan c'est
quand même une opération de
communication qui s'est retournée
totalement contre les objectifs initiaux
qu'elle était censé défendre la défense
des valeurs de la République aujourd'hui
si on regarde objectivement les valeurs
véhiculées par le front Marianne c'est
le copinage et l'entre-soi on l'a dit
tout à l'heure avec avec un processus de
sélection extrêmement opaque ayant
permis en gros de rétribuer des des
copains ou des amis politiques c'est une
forme de sectarisme idéologique parce
que je rappelle que des associations qui
travaillent de longue date avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur notamment SOS
Racisme a été exclu sur la base de
désaccord idéologique et personnel avec
avec Marlène Schiappa de donc des
bénéficiaires du fond Marianne et si
elle gaspillage argent public donc si
aujourd'hui le triptyque des valeurs de
la République ce sont cela voilà c'est
c'est ça les conséquences du fond Marian
c'est qu'aujourd'hui deux associations
et un processus de sélection
biaisé en fait ont aussi entaché y
compris la réputation de 15 autres
associations qui ont qui ont elles
réellement travaillé qui ont été aussi
bénéficiaires de ce fond parce que au
global il y a 17 associations qui ont
bénéficié qui se retrouvent aussi
embarqués et en tâché dans cette
opération qui était finalement ni
feignée à faire mais alors que ce sont
un deux associations qui qui posent
problème sur les 17 donc effectivement
elle est 15 autres sans doute travailler
normalement mais juste un mot parce que
on l'entend mais en fait Claude Raynal
il le dit pas le nom de Samuel Paty
parce qu'il a il a tenu à faire ce que
lui avait demandé la sœur de la semaine
passée de jamais plus associer le fond
Marianne avec avec son nom donc même lui
pendant les auditions il s'est appliqué
à le faire et il le fait également dans
l'interview pour respecter la volonté de
la famille
conséquences politiques après la
conclusion de ce rapport de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale hier
Elisabeth borne elle est Lude cette
question dans son interview parisien je
crois que les conséquences politiques
elles sont déjà là en réalité et qui a
même plus besoin de réaction
ministérielle ou de la première ministre
pour pour qu'il y ait des conséquences
c'est à dire que c'est une affaire par
sa dimension symbolique mais aussi ça
simplicité peut-être parce que
finalement il y a très peu d'acteurs et
on comprend très bien et rapidement ce
qui s'est ce qui a pu se passer des fois
on est dans des affaires extrêmement
complexes etc avec des jeux d'acteurs
beaucoup plus compliqués à des crypter
là c'est malheureusement très simple à
comprendre et donc l'impact dans
l'opinion il est déjà là et on comprend
évidemment et on l'a vu ces dernières
semaines que aucun
parlementaire ou encore moins membres du
gouvernement on a envie de se mouiller
et de se brûler les ailes avec Marlène
Schiappa dans cette dans cette affaire
après quelle boîte les conséquences en
termes de carrière et de peut-être
maniement est-ce que est-ce que Emmanuel
Macron va chercher rapidement avec
filtrer Marlène Schiappa ça je n'en ai
aucun élément mais en tout cas les
conséquences politiques elles sont elles
sont déjà déjà
merci beaucoup Antoine Roger merci et
tous vos articles sont allés évidemment
sur le site de Mediapart merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin Quentin merci
beaucoup je rappelle le titre de votre
documentaire fond Ariane le détournement
d'un symbole c'est avoir ce soir à 17h30
sur notre antenne et vendredi matin à
11h également merci Quentin dans 20
minutes dans le cas des territoires on
reviendra sur l'interview d'Elizabeth
borne Parisien Aujourd'hui en France à
l'affiche sa fermeté fait le bilan des
100 jours alors qu'Emmanuel Macron doit
prendre la parole vendredi on va en
parler et on en parle tout de suite avec
notre invité politique Olivier du socle
nous rejoins